字幕: Harue Mori
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
こんにちは 幡野といいます
僕は36歳 写真家をしています
写真家というのは たくさんの人と出会い
いろんな場所に行きます
僕にとってカメラというのは
人や場所と繋げてくれるものです
写真家というのは
見聞の広がる とてもたのしい仕事です
僕は東京の郊外で
妻と３歳の息子と暮らしています
生まれたばかりの頃は
何もできなかった息子が
今では自分で歩いて
自分で食事をしてくれます
泣くことでしか意思を伝えられなかったのが
今では言葉で伝えてくれます
育児というのは
大変なこともありますが
子どもの成長とともに
日々 楽になっていることを感じます
たのしい仕事をして
家族や友人に恵まれ
ストレスとは無縁の 不自由のない
しあわせな生活を送っています
僕は 一見すると健康そうに見えますが
血液がんの患者です
現代の医療では治すことができない
病気にかかっています
今はこうして
立って話すことができますが
いずれ 体を起こすことも
痛みや苦しさで会話をすることも
できなくなるでしょう
もしくは体調が急変して １ヶ月後には
もう死んでいるかもしれません
人間は 誰でもいつか 必ず死にます
これは 仕方がないことです
しかし 苦しんで死ぬということが
僕には耐えることができません
苦しさというのは
身体的なことだけではありません
好きなことができなくなり
嫌なことを押し付けられ
自由を奪われるという苦しさが
僕には耐えられません
自由というのは人間の尊厳であり
アイデンティティの基礎になります
人間は 生きているから素晴らしいのではなく
自由であるから素晴らしいんです
この自由が 病気になると
奪われようとします
しかし 病気が自由を奪うわけではありません
では 誰が病人から
自由を奪ってしまうのでしょうか
それは 病人の周りにいる家族によって
自由が奪われてしまうんです
家族というのは
「一分一秒でも長く生きてほしい」
そう願います
一見すると とても聞こえがいい言葉ですが
少し見方を変えると
自分の家族が死んでしまうことの
悲しみの先送りでしかありません
自分が悲しみたくないから
自分が心配をしたくないから
自分が安心をするために
病人の自由を奪ってしまうんです
ゆっくりしていなさいと
病人をベッドに寝かせて
本人の望まない治療や 延命措置を
施してしまうこともあります
本人の意思に関係なく
家族の判断によって
回復の見込みがないのに
機械によって強制的に生かす延命措置を
僕は正しいとは思いません
自由を奪うということは
人間の尊厳を奪う行為です
医者は患者の希望ではなく
家族の希望を優先します
患者が延命措置を拒否していても
家族が延命措置を求めれば
医者は延命措置を施します
運転免許証の裏にある
臓器提供意思カード
あれに 本人が提供する意思の
サインをしていても
家族が反対をすれば
臓器提供はされません
日本には 病人の意思を保障する方法が
一切ありません
僕たちの命は
僕たちが決めるのではなく
悲しみたくない という
家族によって決定されます
僕の妻は 僕の意思を尊重すると思います
しかし 僕の親族や妻の親族が
妻にプレッシャーを与えます
そのプレッシャーに
妻が負けてしまう可能性だってあります
日本の医療レベルというのは 世界的に見て
とても高い水準を保っています
しかしそれは 助けることができる
命に限った話です
助けることができない命に対して
日本の医療というのは
とても低いと言わざるを得ません
僕は自分の尊厳を守るために
安楽死をすることを検討しています
安楽死というのは 日本では違法行為のため
海外に行ってやることになります
しかしこれは そう簡単な話ではありません
体調が急変したり
タイミングが一つでもずれれば
海外に行って安楽死ということは
できないでしょう
僕は実際に 安楽死をするための
会員登録を済ませていますが
実際に安楽死ができる可能性というのは
とても低いと考えています
おそらくできないでしょう
日本人が海外で安楽死をするというのは
とてもハードルが高いことです
日本国内でも安楽死ができるように
法律を変える必要があると
僕は考えています
自分の命を 自然な寿命で
全うしたいという人
延命措置をしてでも
生きたいという人
これ以上苦しみたくないから
安楽死をしたいという人
それぞれの価値観に対応していくには
選択肢の幅を広げるしかありません
そしてその選択肢を 家族ではなく
患者本人が選ぶ必要があります
家族であろうと 誰であろうと
人の価値観を否定してはいけないのです
人の価値観を否定して
自分の価値観を押し付けることが
自由を奪う第一歩です
全ては 価値観の否定から始まります
安楽死の話をすると 多くの人が
最後の死に方だけを注目します
しかし 本当に大切なことは
死に方ではなく 生き方です
好きなことをして自由に生きる
というのが 僕にとっては大切な生き方です
安楽死を選択することによって
最後に苦しまなくていい
という安心感が
生きやすさを後押ししてくれます
いつでも楽に死ぬことができる
そう考えることによって
ギリギリまで 最後まで頑張って
生きようという気持ちになります
「諦めるんじゃない」「がんばれ」
こういった言葉は健康な方から
たくさん言われてきました
これらの言葉は 助からない患者にとって
毒になる言葉です
僕は 自分の人生を諦めているわけでもなく
死にたいわけでもなく
ただ 最後まで たのしく生きたいだけです
僕は 自分の死と向き合うことで
「生きることとはなんだろう？」
ということも
よく考えるようになりました
人は いつか死んでしまうのに
どうして生まれて 生きるんでしょうか
僕がたどり着いた答えは
人は人それぞれのしあわせを
享受するために生きている ということです
僕のしあわせと
誰かのしあわせは違います
自分のしあわせを見つけて
それを享受することが
生きる理由だと僕は考えています
子どもというのは
自ら進んで嫌なことはしません
自ら進んでやることは
たのしいことばかりです
子どもの好きなことを自由にやらせていれば
子どもはずっと笑顔です
本当は誰もが 子どもの時に
感じていたことを
大人になる途中で
忘れてしまったのかもしれません
しあわせを享受するという
とても簡単な答えを
僕は大きな病気をするまで
気付けていませんでした
そして健康な時に持っていた
欲の意味のなさにも気付きます
たとえば お金や名誉
女性にモテたい
いわゆる男性が想像しがちな
欲の意味のなさにも気付きます
これらは あの世に一緒に
持っていけるわけではないので
死ぬ人間にとっては
必要がないものです
病気になった今
僕は 自分の欲やしあわせではなく
誰かのしあわせを願うようになりました
妻や息子のしあわせや
友人たちのしあわせを
心から願っています
付き合った時間の長さではなく
付き合った時間の質が大切になり
たった数時間しか会わなかった人の
しあわせを願うようになりました
もしかしたら
本当のしあわせというのは
誰かのしあわせを願えること
なのかもしれません
そして 誰かのしあわせを願うには
まず自分がしあわせでなければ
心からは願えないでしょう
そして 自分がしあわせになるには
自由が保障されていなければなりません
生きることや しあわせについて
皆さんもぜひ考えてみてください
自分や家族が大きな病気になった時に
必ず 役に立ちます
（拍手）